[Music]
hey everyone
in today's video we're going to be
discussing an important scene
that was cut from the films entirely a
scene
that a lot of you have probably never
seen it takes place in little whinging
and involves harry as well as all three
of the dursleys
vernon petunia and most importantly
dudley
the scene in question is part of the
books but
never made it into the movies despite
being filmed as filmmakers felt that it
just didn't fit however in my opinion
the removal of this scene was a bit of
an injustice to the dursleys
as it was an opportunity for redemption
it showed the humanity of their
characters
and effectively conveyed that they
weren't necessarily pure evil
they were just human and scared like the
rest of us
the scene also completed dudley
dursley's character arc
this scene would have taken place years
after dudley was attacked by dementors
in the order of the phoenix
and years after he was saved by his
freak
cousin harry the dementor attack was a
profound moment for dudley
as it allowed him to finally realize his
faults
jk rowling put it best herself though
dementor attacks are almost
never a good thing this one was people
usually ask me
what is it the dudley saw during the
dementor attack
rowling said my feeling is that he saw
himself
exactly for what he was and for a boy
that spoiled
it would be terrifying so he was jolted
out of it
dementor attacks aren't usually good for
people but this one was
being attacked by dementors and being
forced to view his own
horrible traits then being saved by the
very boy that he tormented
had a profound impact on deadly an
impact that became evident
during chapter 3 of the deathly hallows
the dursleys departing
the deleted scene from the films more or
less gives us a massively simplified
version
this chapter which actually has quite a
lot of depth
given that the chapter was already
condensed into so little
i'm surprised and a little disappointed
that they cut it from the final film
in this chapter the dersies are finally
departing their home on privet drive
and being escorted to safety prompting a
series of awkward goodbyes between harry
and vernon
as well as harry and petunia however
harry's goodbye with dudley was actually
rather
profound it all started with a cup of
tea
there's no need harry muttered but uncle
vernon made any further explanation
unnecessary
by saying loudly well this is goodbye
then boy
he swung his right arm upward to shake
harry's hand but at the last moment
seemed unable to face it and merely
closed his fist and began swinging it
backward and forward
like a metronome ready daddy asked
petunia
fussily checking the clasp of a handbag
so as to avoid looking at harry
altogether
dudley did not answer but stood there
with his mouth slightly ajar
reminding harry little of the giant
grape he had already reached a living
room door when dudley mumbled
i don't understand what don't you
understand popkin
asked petunia looking up at her son
dudley raised a large
ham-like hand to point at harry why
isn't he coming with us
uncle vernon and aunt petunia froze when
they stood staring at dudley as though
he'd just expressed a desire
to become a ballerina what said uncle
vernon loudly
why isn't he coming too asked dudley
well
he doesn't want to said uncle vernon
turning to glare at harry and adding
you don't want to do you not in the
slightest
said harry there you are uncle vernon
told dudley now come on
we're off he marched out of the room
they heard the front door open
but dudley did not move and after a few
faltering steps
aunt petunia stopped too what now barked
uncle vernon
reappearing in the doorway it seemed the
dudley was struggling with concepts
too difficult to put into words after
several moments of apparently painful
internal struggle
he said but where's he going to go the
beginning of this chapter is significant
because we start to see a side of dudley
that we had never seen before
the dursleys were leaving little
whinging to head to safety and while
vernon and petunia were more than happy
to get out of there
not particularly worried about harry
dudley feels differently
dudley starts to show genuine care for
harry's while being here
and everyone's shocked especially his
parents aunt petunia and uncle vernon
looked at each other
it was clear that dudley was frightening
them hestia jones
broke the silence but surely you know
where your nephew is going
she asked looking bewildered certainly
we know said vernon dursley
he's off with some of your lot isn't he
right dudley get in the car
you heard the men we're in a hurry again
vernon desley marched as far as the
front door but dudley did not follow
off with some of our lot hestia looked
outraged
harry had met this attitude before
witches and wizards
seemed stunned but his closest living
relatives took so little interest in the
famous harry potter
it's fine harry assured her it doesn't
matter honestly
doesn't matter repeated hestia her voice
rising considerably
don't these people realize what you've
been through what danger you're in
the unique position you hold in the
hearts of the anti-voldemort movement
no they don't said harry they think i'm
a waste of space
actually but i'm used to i don't think
you're a waste of space
if harry had not seen dudley's lips move
he might not have believed it
as it was he stared at dudley for
several seconds before accepting that it
must have been his cousin who had spoken
for one thing dudley had turned red
harry was embarrassed
and astonished himself well uh thanks
dudley
again dudley appeared to grapple with
thoughts too unwieldy for expression
before mumbling you saved my life not
really said harry
it was your soul the dementor would have
taken he looked curiously at his cousin
they had virtually no contact during
this summer or last
as harry had come back to private drive
so briefly and kept to his room
so much it now dawned on harry however
that the cup of cold tea on which he had
rodden that morning
might not have been a booby trap at all
although rather touched he was
nevertheless quite relieved that dudley
appeared to have exhausted his ability
to express his feelings
after opening his mouth once or twice
more dudley subsided into scarlet
faced silence and when the time came for
the dursleys to finally
properly leave dudley took another
opportunity to make his peace with harry
revealing that he had truly genuinely
changed
dudley gently released himself from his
mother's clutches and walked toward
harry
who had to repress an urge to threaten
him with magic then dudley held out his
large
pink hand blimey dudley said harry of
aunt petunia's renewed
sobs did the dementors blow a different
personality into you
dunno mutter dudley see you harry yeah
said harry taking dudley's hand and
shaking it maybe
take care big d dudley nearly smiled
they lumbered from the room
harry heard his heavy footfalls on the
gravel drive and then a car door slammed
the deleted scene from the film omits
most of this however
as it simply shows deadly awkwardly
walking up to harry and saying i don't
think you're a waste of space
before shaking his hand the events of
chapter 3
revealed the type of man the dudley had
transformed into
a good solid man that genuinely cared
for those that were close to him
an unimaginably vast improvement from
the spoiled
insensitive tormentous boy of years past
dudley was only awful because he was
raised that way and his ability to shake
it off
and turn into a genuinely decent person
as he got older
is certainly something to be admired
this scene effectively brought peace to
harry
dudley's relationship and the tea that
dudley left at harry's doorstep
was really symbolic for the change that
he had undergone
in the words of sirius black we've all
got both light and dark inside us
what matters is the part we choose to
act on that's who we really are
and that's it for this video did you
guys know about this scene
are you upset that they left it out of
the films let me know in the comment
section
below if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe
to the channel
[Music]
you